hier à new york accord entre américains
et soviétiques l'ont mis à plat sauva
parlera librement dans un salon de
l'aéroport là messieurs bonsoir c'est en
effet une très grande figure de
l'histoire est aussi un grand seigneur
qui vient de quitter cet après-midi le
20e siècle et de manière tragique
l'amiral man bête compte de birmanie est
mort en mer dans l'explosion de son
bateau explosion d'origine criminelle ou
nous sommes pratiquement sûrs déjà
certains membres de l'ira les
catholiques extrémistes des relents du
nord revendique ce geste geste odieux
le corps du petit fils de lord
mountbatten le jeune nicolas 15 ans a
été retrouvé peu après dans le port de
merak morts c'est là que s'est passé le
drame
l'amiral parfait pour une partie de
pêche en compagnie de son petit-fils et
d'un marin cinq minutes à peine après le
départ de la vedette
le bateau explosé ainsi s'achevait la
vie exceptionnellement riche de cet
homme de 79 ans arrière petit fils de la
reine victoria oncle tout à la fois de
la reine et du prince philip il pu leur
témoin au mariage
marin il avait au début de la guerre vu
son navire endommagé d'un
écoute de norvège puis torpillé en mer
du nord puis coulé en crète il avait
toujours survécu
et aujourd'hui ils meurent en mer ne
savais pas pourtant avec phase de
l'uniforme il tint tout au long de sa
vie des postes les plus importants donc
au finir celui de premier lord de
l'amirauté comme son père l'avait été
durant la première guerre en 44 premier
commandant suprême allié en asie du
sud-est il avait en birmanie vaincu les
japonais après des combats féroces et il
reçut la reddition des forces japonaises
au cours d'une cérémonie où en une seule
image on saisit le tempérament de cet
homme exceptionnel
nous voici venir
troisième à partir de la gauche le
maréchal leclerc il s'appelait depuis ce
temps-là lorgues louis mountbatten de
birmanie
puis et l'inde vous dans l'indépendance
le gouvernement travailliste maman mme
batten vice roi des indes afin que le
départ des britanniques pu se faire en
douceur sans effusion de sang dans la
paix dans l'honneur des uns et des
autres et à tous ses titres de gloire
s'ajoute celui de négociateur habile et
de grands diplomates en un instant
difficile
si la grande-bretagne super tir bien ses
commandes bas tenait sa femme avait avec
gandhi les meilleurs rapports personnels
dieu sait pourtant contre ces deux
hommes là il y avait un monde de
différence dans la conception des plans
pour nous français man battle restera
comme celui qui préparera les raid de
commandos sur nos côtes d'occuper celui
qui devait ensuite mettre au point de
débarquement libérateur de jeu à 44
après la guerre il s'attacha à l'oeuvre
des collèges du monde unis c'est à dire
les jeunes et la paix dont il passe à la
présidence au prince de galles son jeune
neveu en nous expliquant avec humour
tout récemment pourrait penser que c'est
une chose très très important à bien
campés de rogers face à 19 points
hélas - comme attentant moins tranchant
pas ce moment même à exactement que les
plus anciens de nos anciens
et pour vous dire la marque a laissé
leur demande maintenant nam sachez que
un deuil national de sept jours vient
d'être décrétée agneaux des donc pour la
vie de leur demande d'être l'une des
plus fortes personnalités de la grande
bretagne est l'un de ceux qui restera
dans ces manuels d'histoire
les historiens se souviendront aussi
quand cette année 79 10 ans après les
grandes émeutes de belfast et de
londonderry
l'iran a remis le feu aux poudres du
dossier irlandais déjà quelques jours
avant l'arrivée au pouvoir la même tâche
heures l'un de ses collaborateurs les
plus fidèles devaient disparaître dans
un attentat semblable lui aussi
revendiqué par l'ira georges bortoli oui
c'était il ya cinq mois presque jour
pour jour et dans l'enceinte même de la
chambre des communes ce sanctuaire de la
démocratie britannique
le porte parole conservateur pour
l'irlande du nord monsieur airs et neave
un proche de même satcher été tuées par
une explosion en sortant sa voiture sa
voiture piégée du parking de la chambre
etc d'attentât et est immédiatement
revendiqué par l'armée de libération
nationale irlandaise une branche
dissidente de l'ira provisoire c'est à
dire de la branche la plus terroriste de
d organisation irlandaise
on sait pas très bien si c'est cette
armée de libération bien si c'est l'irak
qui a fait l'explosion de cet après midi
peu importe il s'agit de toute façon je
ne les lis turner de national il s'agit
bien d'un attentat et la police pense
qu'il s'agit d'une bombe de 25 kg qui
été télécommandée
alors ce qui est certain c'est que cet
attentat sera ressentie en grande
bretagne comme une escalade dans le
terrorisme irlandais il y avait eu déjà
des attentats spectaculaires
non le voir de compte le sionisme il y
avait en mars dernier également le
meurtre de l'ambassadeur britannique à
la haye
mais lord mountbatten c'était une figure
nationale c'était le symbole
l'angleterre en battant de l'angleterre
invaincue ce soir la bbc toutes les
télévisions britanniques ont bouleversé
leurs programmes pour lui rendre un
hommage solennel c'était un personnage
national et international vous venez
parler du deuil en inde
donc je crois qu'il est pas du tout
exagéré de dire que ce soir le
terrorisme irlandais a marqué un grand
pas dans une nouvelle escalade
deuxième point chaud de l'actualité ce
soir l'aéroport kennedy à new york bien
depuis deux trois heures il semble bien
que nous assistions là une certaine
détente il paraît certain que soviétique
américains se sont mis d'accord pour
mettre fin à la tente des 67 passagers
de l'iliouchine bloqué depuis vendredi
vous le savez sur une piste de
l'aéroport
il semble en effet que lou nina vla
sauvage vers la femme du danseur étoile
alexandre godounov qui avait demandé la
ville aux états unis que lumina vlas va
donc est accepté ou bien qu'on ait
accepté pour elle de sortir de l'avion
afin d'être interrogé dans un salon de
l'aéroport par les responsables
américains qui ont envie de savoir si
l'ue ne laissera veut vraiment partir à
moscou sans son mari
dans quelques minutes nous aurons au
bout du fil notre envoyé spécial à new
york
jacques cycle en attendant ceux ci
encore à l'étranger en 3 télégramme
d'abord une année record pour
l'immigration des juifs soviétiques
cinquante mille d'entre eux ont émigré
en israël des chiffres donnés par les
dissidents juifs vivant à moscou
et puis les mots très durs de georges
marchais ce matin à alger mots très durs
à l'égard d'israël politique criminelle
a dit le secrétaire général du parti
communiste qui s'est déclaré très
inquiet par la situation provoquée par
tel aviv au proche orient
georges marchais a parlé d' attitude
agressive au sud liban et à l'égard des
palestiniens
enfin la nomination d'un nouveau nonce
apostolique à paris c'est à dire d'un
nouveau représentant du vatican
monseigneur felice à ne pas confondre
avec le cardinal pellissier c'est un
homme de caractère qui a déjà fait ses
preuves en promettant un petit peu
d'ordre dans la maison de dieu
aux pays-bas les affaires françaises
maintenant à commencer par deux
mauvaises nouvelles sur le front des
prix le mauvais indice de juillet 1,3
vous êtes on dit en titre philippe
sassier nous dira ce qu'il faut en
penser et puis d'abord ce point pas très
satisfaisant sur les conséquences de la
libération des loyers un peu partout à
paris comme en province nos
correspondants et les journalistes de
notre service économique
on constate et vous allez le voir
quelques bavures en forme date
jean claude renaud précisons d'abord que
la libération des loyers intervenu le
1er juillet ne concerne pas les
logements soumis à la loi de 1948
ni les hlm pour les autres c'est à dire
pour 5 millions de logements neufs ou
anciens
le propriétaire peut désormais fixer
librement le montant du loyer au moment
du renouvellement du bail mécary a un
mais les organisations nationales de
propriétaires se sont engagés auprès du
gouvernement à modérer les hausses en
clair d'après cet engagement
l'augmentation du loyer ne devrait pas
dépasser dans tous les cas 17,73 % or
aujourd'hui les locataires à leurs
associations constatent que les housses
pulvérise ce plafond un exemple à
particules payer un loyer de 2250 francs
elle cherche comprise et un
enregistrement compris c'est à dire
s'accepte un loyer des demis france sur
la base et 2030 et à l'air maintenant le
gérant me fait une proposition de bail
avec un ne revoyait qui sera sur la base
de trois mille francs par mois plus les
charges cette fois les charges seront
plus et ont fait leur vocation de
l'augmentation de leurs de l'après 50%
j'avais des explications c'est à dire
qu'il ya d'une part eu la mise en place
d'un ascenseur qui a été fait entre
temps lent plus on nous demande un
rappel
jusqu'en octobre dernier c'est à dire
que le gérant veut faire démarrer le
bail de 8 à 9 mois avant alors qu'à
cette époque là les voiliers
développeurs comme la presse la
confédération nationale du logement a
relevé des cas encore plus édifiant 67 %
de hausse pour un quatre pièces à
haguenau 110% pour un f3 bry-sur-marne
120% pour un f3 à nice quels sont les
moyens de défense des locataires un seul
d' écrire au préfet de leur département
à paris le bureau de la préfecture
chargé de recueillir les plaintes et
submergé d'appels téléphoniques
il recevra il faut écrire au préfet et
c'est lui
après étude des dossiers qui réunira les
représentants des propriétaires pour les
rappeler à l'ordre
cela dit si le propriétaire ne veut pas
respecter les recommandations du préfet
rien ne l'en empêche
aucune mesure de contrainte n'est prise
résultat les locataires sont démunis
devant les hausses excessives des loyers
et cela alors qu'ils redoutent une
augmentation sévère des charges cet
hiver de 30 à 50% selon les prévisions
de la confédération des administrateurs
de biens
et voilà qui n'a pas contribué à
redresser un indice des prix franchement
médiocre pour le mois dernier 1,3 à de
hausse pour le seul mois de juillet on
n'avait pas approché pareil chiffres
depuis deux ans et quatre mois phillips
a ses hauts et ses terres qu'il faut
remonter à avril 1917 juillet 1974
préfecture m'en trouver un 1,3 pour cent
bien évidemment la flambée des loyers on
en parlait tout à l'heure à peser sur
cet indice en juillet dernier en 1918
était 1,2 pour cent et voyez au cours de
ces trois derniers mois gars c'est de
loin le plus mauvais indice enregistre
et maintenant ce qu'il faut dire c'est
que si la france est soumise et une
nouvelle reprise l'inflation et bien
c'est un phénomène que l'on constate
partout et qui est inquiétant regarder
pour le premier semestre de cette année
aux états unis
antoine ul vous a calculé que cette
hausse des prix atteignait 14 %
les allemands restent salle 7 5% les
grands la grande bretagne près de 16% et
la france
11,3 pour c'est une prévision
c'est le premier semestre jusqu'au mois
de juin à ce que l'on peut dire c'est
que la france on peut voir ces chiffres
les 10 dans les premiers qui sont les
plus aptes ou non plus dans les derniers
lots maintenant qu'est-ce qui fait que
l'inflation reprend pour ces différents
pays étant tous les salaires tantôt les
prises alimentaires
tantôt les charges diverses et bien en
france pour le mois de juillet et bien
sony nous votre bouche est née votre
épicier le marchand de fruits et légumes
qui a fait monter les prix
0 8% pour l'alimentation ça ce qu'on
appelait service c'est-à-dire tout ce
qu'est les garages de coiffer le
coiffeur on a très fortement augmenté
mais les services des rats 1 6% due aux
escales du prix en inde il ya beaucoup
30 libéré puis relie à les voiliers
avaient allumé 6% 1
il ya aussi tous les transports et où
donc c'est un indice qui est assez fort
sur des sexes et puis il ya les produits
manufacturés clair les produits de
l'industrie et ça c'est également un
phénomène mondial dans l'occident tous
les pays tous les produits de
l'industrie continue à augmenter depuis
le début d'année fortement 1,7 pour cent
l'automobile par exemple 5% de hausse
mais où on ne peut pas s'attendre aussi
bien en france qu'ailleurs un bond après
un bon indice des prix dans les mois qui
viennent alors justement après pareille
indices le smic devrait être de relever
de 2 1% en septembre et puisque nous
parlons de hausse
sachez que la sncf augmentera de 5 5%
ses tarifs voyageurs à partir du 1er
septembre
déjà la société nationale des chemins de
fer avait augmenté ses tarifs le 1er
février de 7 5%
et puis petite compensation le conseil
des ministres de mercredi devrait
relever le montant de l'aide à la
rentrée scolaire la prime était de 170
francs pour les familles à revenus
modérés
elle pourrait atteindre 200 ou même 300
francs réponse donc mercredi à l'issue
de ce conseil
va-t-on enfin vers une politique à long
terme pour l'aménagement du littoral en
france et littoral qui se dégradent et
jour après jour le plus souvent à cause
du béton chacun construit vous savez un
petit peu n'importe où et surtout
n'importe comment et bien aujourd'hui le
premier ministre vient de prendre un
ensemble de mesures pour protéger les
côtes françaises
un exemple les constructions seront
désormais interdite à moins de 100
mètres d'arrivage les concessions
privées sur les plages seront interdites
les marinas et route de corniche
également seront proscrites les marais
les dunes forêts seront davantage
protégés
il est temps car sur les 5500 kilomètres
du littoral 3000 sont déjà urbanisées
cela dit ce n'est peut-être peut faire
reculer le problème de quelques
kilomètres seulement de plus en plus en
effet les promoteurs et puis les
particuliers sentant venir le danger
construisent anarchiquement à
l'intérieur des terres ni temps les
terres littéralement le paysage et
provoquant la chaleur à peyragudes béton
sur mer vous connaissez protéger le
littoral certes mais bien souvent le mal
est déjà fait et puis le plan
d'occupation des sols imposé à toutes
les communes du littoral avaient rendu
ces dernières années toutes ces zones
inconstructibles alors l'astuce a
consisté à se rendre à 8 ou 10 km de là
afin d'acheter un lopin de terre et d'y
édifier une résidence des constructions
anarchiques sur ces terrains cultivables
c'est ce qu'on appelle le mitage
aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit que le mitage
pratiqué à outrance
non seulement menace l'écologie mais
aussi qu'ils mettent en péril
l'agriculture d'une région vers on a
permet d'abord parce qu'il n'y avait pas
de mesures qui pouvaient l'interdire et
qu'ensuite les gens venant sollicité
souvent des petits propriétaires
exploitants que l'on exploite en leur
donnant un prix qui étaient nettement
supérieurs à du prix agricoles les gens
se sont laissés convaincre et on vend du
vin à votre antara mais alors les
agriculteurs se plaignent mais
finalement c'est eux qui ont vendu le
terrain bien que les agriculteurs wii à
travers il ya des agriculteurs sans
doute mais qui réagissait plus sans
propriétaire d'abord parce que
généralement ces régions se sont pas des
gens sur des exploitations très
importante et les quelques millions
d'anciens francs qu'on peut leur
proposer leur apparaissait comme un gain
intéressant et en plus ils avaient
l'impression très souvent que
l'agriculture allait se terminer avec
eux parce qu'il ya les en pratique ses
soeurs et finalement cette parcelle qui
partait ne parachève ne les gênait pas
trop qui pouvait sérieusement imaginer
que notre pays pourrait se priver
d'agriculture une agriculture qui
évoluent les techniques nouvelles
s'applique à des terres de plus en plus
vastes rentabilité oblige
d'autre part à cause du mitage les
terrains se sont valorisés en vendée ils
ont été multipliées par 15 impossible à
acheter pour un jeune agriculteur
oui on a moins de terres à cultiver
on est gêné deuxième aspect par les
constructions qui sont faits tout azimut
disons partout en bordure de chemin de
chant avec les difficultés de voisinage
et la plupart du temps ce seront des
genres des propriétaires qui ne sont pas
gris culte et qui ont vendu donc
l'agriculteur n'a pas les moyens de
l'empêcher de dire face et à son
détriment balle à terre et par malgré
lui pour empêcher il est obligé de
l'acheter au prix terrains bâtis à 10
fois ou ou quand c'est pas vingt fois le
prix de la terre agricole
les rapports entre paysans et nouveaux
habitants se sont tendues pourtant le
mitage a connu un grand succès sans
doute parce qu'il n'était pas perçu
forcément comme un inconvénient la
construction de résidences dans une
petite commune est une source de profit
la population augmente le budget aussi
d'autre part cela fait marcher le
bâtiment le secteur du bâtiment jusqu'à
présent n'a pas été trop touché encore
peu actuellement à 100 de permis et
reviennent refusé étant donné que
la chambre d'agriculture émet un avis
défavorable mais si
la personne est impliquée
constamment est certain que le bâtiment
sera touchée à soullans vendu lié sa
emploie quand même meilleur dizaine de
personnes nous sont pas contre la
construction est rien ce que nous
voulons c'est mettre de l'ordre qui
n'est pas sous prétexte de la liberté
est totale de tout le monde tout le
monde s'installe là pour tous les
lotissements les plans d'occupation des
sols c'est peut être une solution il
peut y en avoir d'autres
l'essentiel étant de mettre fin aux
anarchie oui ne nous leurrons pas le
problème et même le sujet traite et
complète bien ce que nous avons traité
depuis hier littoral et arrière-pays
film un problème est moins voyants mais
c'est le même problème mais ça il faut
bien voir que les jeunes les
agriculteurs sont les jardiniers de la
nature si on supprime les agriculteurs
c'est pas la peine de parler de
protection de la nature alors si on ne
construit pas on va laisser des terres
des espaces en déshérence ça ne tient
pas debout non plus alors les mesures
prises aujourd'hui qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
à écouter en recevant alors il cotait
ans à la nature c'est une directive et
elle a pour intérêt par rapport à toutes
les tout ce qui a été dit avant ou écrit
avancé qu'elle est opposable aux tiers
mais j'avais on peut gouverner par
décrets non ne change pas une société
par décret et surtout une société qui a
dans ce domaine des mauvaises habitudes
et plein de défauts alors il apparaît
que ya beaucoup dia tu centre finalement
la volonté de l'état et la réalité
locale parce que sur le terrain ça se
passe différemment alors pour le
littoral c'est parti avant significatif
la pression est formidable sur le
littoral tout le temps vous avez
beaucoup plus d'urbanisation partout
ailleurs en france
vous avez une pression touristique qui
est persistante et qui s'accroît d'année
en année et puis en même temps vous avez
une pression foncière fantastique parce
que des 13 millions propriétaires
fonciers en france
et la proportion est encore supérieure
sur le littoral alors ça fait dix ans
qu'on vit qu'il faut des plans
d'occupation des sols
aujourd'hui sur le littoral on peut dire
fiona quatre sur dix qui sont approuvés
et opposable mais il va falloir tous les
refaire dans les quatre ans qui viennent
c'est la directive qu'il dit alors il
faut espérer que cette qu'ils ont cette
révision sera déchirante et que les élus
et les citoyens et notamment ceux qui
défendent la nature
se confronteront pour s'opposer aux
groupes de pression qui sont nombreux je
parle des professionnels de l'immobilier
et des propriétaires fonciers
enfin de tous ceux qui ont intérêt à
exploiter la nature alors donc qui
dépend je dirais y dépend de l'état fixé
les grandes règles mais ça dépend pas de
lui que ces règles soient appliquées
alors la directive est bonne mais je
dirais qui vivra verra
quittant pas tout à fait les côtés et
l'arrière pays nous avons en effet
décidé et tout au long de cette semaine
de faire un bilan des vacances 79 vous
verrez des enquêtes tous les soirs à 20h
dans le journal et puis demain antenne
de midi accès tout spécialement autour
de ce dossier avec en invité les
principaux protagonistes
alors disons que schématiquement cette
saison aura été marqué par un départ
plus tardif des estivants en raison du
temps plutôt maussade par un
raccourcissement la durée des séjours et
par une tendance très nette des
touristes à moins dépenser ce soir
premier volet de notre enquête la côte
d'azur avec de nice breil où les
français cette année au mieux étaler
leurs vacances où ils vont ailleurs où
ils ont moins de sous en tout cas le
département du var c'est c'était se
plaint de sa clientèle française assez
bonne saison 10 l'office du tourisme
moyenne saison disent les commerçants
l'année dernière les touristes qui
avaient vu la bretagne et s'était
rabattu sur les côtes du midi
méditerranéen avait fait de l'année 60
18 dans le var une année exceptionnelle
de 30 % supérieur à la normale les
commerçants varois cette année constate
une diminution du pouvoir d'achat
variant de 15 à 20%
on a pu sortir quand même une baisse du
moyen des moyens financiers de la
clientèle je me souviens avoir eu
l'occasion de me trouver sur un parking
d'un hôtel de la région
à 11 heures du soir les clients qui
sandwich est si je puis dire
preuve en est aussi ça en tête on peut
rencontrer dans certains établissements
qui le matin se lève à 7h prennent les
tartes un petit le jeu n'est vraiment
super complet de façon à éviter des
jeunes à midi on ne les revoit le soir
arrivée à l'hôtel qu'avec le panier
repas il ne sentait pas vous entrepris
par les hôteliers telles choses
absolument pas puisque je vois pour mon
établissement nous
une augmentation de l'ordre de 9% sur
l'année et les prix des menus qui sont
cette année étaient ceux en vigueur
l'année dernière donc absolument aucune
augmentation sur un an
c'est à l'hôtel j'ai un petit hôtel
juste derrière la cuisse derrière la
plage et puis et qui est très agréable
est ce qu'elles considèrent que les prix
ont augmenté cette année par le rapport
aux autres années c'est moi parlez pas
obligé voiliers de taper niçoise par
jour un coude rose et de temps en temps
mais c'est vrai des durs à ce point là a
séduit face à une clientèle française de
plus en plus attentive à ces dépenses
les offices de tourisme on ont prospecté
à l'étranger dans les hôtels des anglais
des américains des allemands
quant aux français ils s'en font la
plupart sur les terrains de camping
comme relais et toutes ces allemands qui
car même à porte
en fait cet entrain de devenir cette
côte d'azur c'est en train de devenir
l'espagne je viens depuis ben t'as mis
sur la côte sud et j'aime la france et
chez me labi ici mais pour vous c'est
intéressant avec le changement pour moi
il ya eu plus de monde mais moins de
recettes
la riviera côte d'azur est contente
d'elle elle aura reçu cette année
environ six millions de vacanciers un
office du tourisme optimiste et
satisfait de ses efforts annonce plus de
français est plus étranger en cette
saison d'été les terrains de camping
moins nombreux que dans le var affiche
complet les hôtels aussi malgré la
hausse des prix quant aux restaurants ce
sont paradoxalement les plus chers et
les moins chers qui auront le mieux
travailler il est vrai que le français
dépensent peut-être un petit peu moins
que l'année dernière parce qu'il a peur
il a peur pour la rentrée
tout augmente l essence pétrole tout ça
alors il fait attention mais il ya du
qu'il ya du monde il ya du français il
ya du talent du tourisme dans l'ensemble
ça va on fait un petit venu à 30 francs
qui est conventionné on sert nos clients
avec ce menu à 30 fois exactement comme
un client qui va dépenser 7 ou 800
francs par tête et ça arrive chez nous
puisque malak la marchandise pour si
vous voulez lui prendre cet argent
puisque on est là pour ça et il ya eu
beaucoup de petits bonus est vrai mais
enfin juste les autres années vous le
sentez
oui grâce la ville des parfums continue
d'être un pôle d'attraction sur la
riviera des cars de touristes viennent
tous les jours
apprendre la fabrication consent on
renifle
mais cette année on achète moi il ya
incontestablement une augmentation de
fréquentation est beaucoup plus de
touristes mais il est évident que la
crise que nous connaissons enfin les
achats donc il y a moins d'achats par
rapport à l'augmentation de mythologie
par rapport aux années précédentes ces
deux exemples donc la saison n'a pas été
très bonne pour vous un très bon et
c'est le seul chiffre d'affaires avait
suivi l'augmentation de fréquentation
ont fait une excellente affaire
mais c'est bon sens
même les prix souvenir cette année se
vendent moins bien à vallauris on est
morose ça marchait mieux il ya quelques
temps cette année c'est un peu plus dur
cette baisse de fréquentation n'est pas
dû aussi peut-être à la baisse de la
qualité des dossiers de valoriser à
lincent sourire oui ça oui oui parce
qu'il ya une floraison d'objets de
mauvais goût il ya de plus en plus de
routier qui s'installe bon si vous
voulez au début après picasso ça a été
un peu la ruée vers l'or n'importe quoi
je vendais n'importe comment et très
bien et maintenant de plus en plus on
arrive à avoir des objets de mauvais
goût les gens ne font pas la différence
se fasse il n'y a pas d'éducation au
niveau de l'âge les gens ne savent pas
faire la différence et achète n'importe
quoi côte varoise et riviera sont encore
cette année les vedettes incontestées du
tourisme on espère voir durer la saison
jusqu'à mi octobre
les français semblent cette année avoir
mieux étaler leurs vacances voilà demain
et dans les jours à venir la même
enquête sur la bretagne l'aquitaine la
normandie et la montagne et puis
maintenant comme promis la
correspondance de jacques signy de new
york sur les dénouements en tout cas les
développements de la sphère place va il
devrait arriver dans quelques instants
la paire donc de cette femme du danseur
mais la question est celle ci les 67
passagers dont 13 enfants ont-ils devoir
passer une quatrième nuit à bord de
l'émission 62 arrêté à kleber porte
depuis vendredi cinq heures de
l'après-midi alors que c'est notre juin
d'andrew yang
monsieur mcdonald's mcd un vie qu'ils
mènent les négociations
en compagnie des soviétiques dans
l'avion des fonctionnaires américains et
non des négociateurs se sont élevées
pour garder un oeil sur l'appareil et
sur la balle arrive comme vous savez on
espère que le dmi la wla sauvage va
pouvoir venir s'expliquer cet après-midi
peut-être devant les autorités
américaines et confirmer si elle désire
réellement rentrer en urss
pendant de longues heures d'attentes des
négociateurs sont restés sur leurs
positions
déployant d'ailleurs le même argument il
s'agit selon les uns et les autres d'une
pure violations des droits de l'homme
disent que le mari lee milad la sauva le
danseur alexander good enough
et quelque part nous dit on non loin de
l'aéroport et qu'ils espèrent
s'entretenir avec sa femme les
américains semblent avoir obtenu que
marina la sovab puisse descendre de
l'avion tandis que l'avocat d'alexandre
goudounov appelle ces mêmes américains à
la fermeté
le président carter n'a pas d'autres
recours
c'est une question de fond de principe
et de doctrines qui dit qu' aujourd'hui
la position américaine
déjà en 1979 président nixon avait mis à
la retraite anticipée un commandant des
gardes-côtes qui avait rendu trop
rapidement aux autorités soviétiques
un jeune matelot demandant l'asile
politique
aujourd'hui le président carter se
trouve confronté à une situation liée
directement à l'un des fondements de sa
propre politique les droits de l'homme
et en abandonnant trop rapidement
ludmila petrova
il risque de se le voir reprocher au
cours de la prochaine campagne
électorale
mais l'épreuve de force pure maintenant
depuis 69 eur et la question est de
savoir quelle solution va-t-on trouver
pour que moscou
tout comme washington puisse sauver la
face mais comment les sports maintenant
cyclisme si vous avez suivi les
championnats du monde de valkenburg vous
êtes sans doute parmi ceux qui ont
trouvé pas très élégante les poussettes
dont a bénéficié le hollandais race qui
a fini par remporter la course
une opinion partagée par bernard hinault
que vient de rencontrer olivier rey
bernard hinault qui de toute façon
n'aurait pas pu jeu en dossier le
maillot arc en ciel il avait à la suite
d'une crevaison raté la bonne échappée
curieux peut-être par la manière dont ça
s'est déroulé moins
effectivement il ya eu beaucoup de
poussière dans son championnat mais déçu
non je crois que la course autrement
elle s'est déroulé à peu près
correctement pour tous les coureurs et
moi j'ai pas eu la chance avec moi
puisque j'ai crevé au moment de la
dernière attaque c'est à dire deux
attaques des huit coureurs et pas
longtemps après géré cassé une roue sans
qui notre permis d'aller devant et vous
ne pensez pas que les commissaires de la
course aurait dû des classes et yann
race même le disqualifier comme il
l'avait fait à dijon pendant le tour de
france sur l'autre landais guéri
cleitman je pense que les commissaires
auraient peut-être dû être beaucoup plus
méchant finalement parce que ça comme ça
et il aura pu déplacer sur le sur le
champ c'est-à-dire qu'à partir du moment
où la faute était fait il fallait
absolument tout de suite le faire
descendre de vélo et ainsi que le
coureur qui l'avait poussé je crois que
c'était sur le champ immédiatement qu'il
fallait le faire
vous ne trouvez pas que ces pratiques
nuisent au cyclisme et à la beauté de ce
sport
effectivement c'est nuit énormément et
je crois que l'année prochaine sur les
championnats du monde il y aura et
commissaires vont avoir une réunion et
que le directeur sportif de chacun
science on sont enseignés à chaque fois
qu'il y aura une poussette de pouvoir
mieux pour je l'espère parce que
autrement ça casse beaucoup de choses et
c'est les pâtes à fait régulier je crois
que vous vous êtes un des rares
champions a répugné vraiment à pratiquer
de telles méthodes
bah je crois que si on est un coureur
cycliste on n'est pas fait pour voir des
poussettes et ne doit pas et 10 et ses
équipiers de cette manière là que ce
sera dur pour nous car les prochaines
précisément ça se passera en france à
sallanches la météo maintenant
aujourd'hui il a plus de la normandie au
nord des alpes sur le reste du pays en
bretagne par exemple un temps assez
ensoleillé et les températures vous le
voyez était en hausse
heureusement car paris avait battu le
record du froid pour le 25 août avec 13
degrés 5
il n'avait pas fait aussi froid sur la
capitale depuis 1873 depuis le début des
relevés météo demain et bien vous le
voyez après dissipation des brouillards
matinaux le temps sera bien ensoleillé
sur la plupart des régions avec
cependant quelques averses près des
frontières du nord et de l'est ainsi
qu'en corse une temps de tendance
orageuse
se développera le soir sur les pyrénées
voilà pour terminer ce journal je vais
vous montrer des images de ce
britannique avec son deltaplane à
traverser la manche ce matin elle a
entendu son aile volante est pipée d'un
petit moteur
ce matin le jeune britannique a bien
décollé du touquet pour continuer son
voyage jusqu'à paris
un voyage qui s'est assez vite terminée
puisque une panne de moteur a contraint
gerry breen que nous voyons ici
traverser la manche à un atterrissage
forcé après seulement 15 km de vol ba
les rendez vous que vous avez maintenant
avec l'information d'abord à 21h40 le
magazine de louis blériot consacré ce
soir à l'espace plus précisément vous le
voyez derrière moi à l'indépendant
spatiale européenne avec la fusée ariane
et bien d'autres fusées vers 23h10 et
bien c'était avec l'autre qui vous
présentera les dernières informations
et puis demain à 12h45 daniel bilalian
vous présentera antenne 2010 bonne
soirée à tous aden